independencia o unionismo la eterna
cuestión en cataluña vuelve a las urnas
en un parlamento fraccionado destacan
dos bloques actualmente la comunidad
autónoma está gobernada por dos partidos
independentistas para estos comicios los
sondeos no muestran tendencias claras y
podrían forjarse nuevas fórmulas de
coalición más allá del independentismo
de las una posibilidad que ha abierto el
socialista salvador y ya quién ha sido
ministro de sanidad del gobierno de
españa hasta hace unas semanas y que ha
recibido el respaldo del presidente
pedro sánchez el desafío que tienes por
delante durante los próximos meses y los
próximos años sin duda alguna se
apasionante es complejo
pero muy necesario necesario para
cataluña muy necesario también para
españa por su parte los independentistas
confían en volver a gobernar para ello
cuentan con la participación en campaña
de algunos líderes independentistas
encarcelados como el exvicepresidente
catalán nuria junqueras en libertad
condicional
ahora dormimos todas las noches en la
cárcel
salimos todas las mañanas a caminar por
las calles del país a estar al lado de
la gente gustaba bay en los debates
electorales se han centrado una vez más
en la cuestión nacional pero han estado
marcados por la pandemia tras acordar
los partidos un retraso en los comicios
la justicia obligó a celebrar las
elecciones justificando que el sufragio
es un derecho fundamental sondeos prevén
una caída histórica en la participación
mientras que ayuntamientos han tenido
que buscar voluntarios para ocupar las
mesas electorales el voto por correo se
ha triplicado y los colegios electorales
se preparan para que voten incluso los
contagiados